while internally you know full well your
product is a disaster for teenagers and
you keep right on doing what you're
doing right not true show them the
pictures would you like to apologize for
what you've done to these good people
why are Senators screaming at Mark
Zuckerberg to apologize for dead
children at a recent Congressional
hearing social media CEOs were forced to
answer to charges that their platforms
had allowed some very bad people to take
advantage of other users including
children now one kid for example was
blackmailed by a scammer on Instagram
and ended up killing himself that's
terrible but it isn't Zuckerberg's Fault
by all means prosecute the bad guys what
the federal lawmakers want to do is make
it easier to sue social media companies
every time something bad happens online
the Senators aren't trying to protect
children they're trying to use emotional
manipulation to gain more regulatory
power over the Internet don't be fooled